i'm going to talk a little bit about
strategy and its relationship with
technology
we tend to think of business strategy as
being a rather abstract body of
essentially economic thought perhaps
rather timeless
i'm going to argue that in fact business
strategy has always been premised on
assumptions about technology that those
assumptions are changing and in fact
changing quite dramatically
and that therefore what that will drive
us to is a different concept of what we
mean by business strategy
let me start if i may with a little bit
of history
the idea of strategy in business owes
its origins to two intellectual giants
bruce henderson the founder of bcg and
michael porter professor at harvard
business school
henderson's central idea was what you
might call the napoleonic idea of
concentrating mass against weakness of
overwhelming the enemy
what henderson recognized was that in
the business world there are many
phenomena which are characterized by
what economists call increasing returns
scale experience the more you do of
something disproportionately the better
you get
and therefore he found a logic for
investing in such kind of overwhelming
mass in order to achieve competitive
advantage and that was the first
introduction of essentially a military
concept of strategy into the business
world
porter
agreed with that premise
but he qualified it he pointed out
correctly that that's all very well but
businesses actually have multiple steps
to them they have different components
and each of those components might be
driven by a different kind of strategy a
company or a business might actually be
advantaged in some activities but
disadvantaged in others
he formed the concept of the value chain
essentially the sequence of steps with
which a shall we say raw material
becomes component becomes assembled into
a finished product and then is
distributed for example
and he argued that advantage accrued to
each of those components and that the
advantage of the whole was in some sense
the sum or the average uh of of that of
its parts
and this idea of the value chain was
predicated on the on the recognition
that what holds a business together is
transaction costs that in essence you
need to coordinate organizations are
more efficient at coordination than
markets very often and therefore the
nature and role and boundaries of the
corporation are defined by transaction
costs
it was on those two ideas
henderson's idea of
increasing returns to scale and
experience and porter's idea of the
value chain encompassing heterogeneous
elements that the whole edifice of
business strategy was subsequently
erected
now what i'm going to argue is that
those premises are in fact being
invalidated
first of all let's think about
transaction costs
there are really two components
transaction costs one is about
processing information and the other is
about communication these are the
economics of processing and
communicating as they have evolved over
a long period of time as we all know
from so many contexts they have been
radically transformed since the days
when porter and henderson first
formulated their theories in particular
since the mid-90s communications costs
have actually been falling even faster
than transaction costs which is why
communication the internet has exploded
in such a dramatic fashion
now those falling transaction costs have
profound consequences because if
transaction costs are the glue that hold
value chains together and they are
falling there is less to economize on
there is less need for vertically
integrated organization and value chains
at least can
break up they need necessarily but they
can
in particular it then becomes possible
for a competitor in one business to use
their position in one step of the value
chain in order to penetrate or attack or
disintermediate the competitor in
another
that is not just an abstract proposition
there are many very specific stories of
how that actually happened a poster
child example was the encyclopedia
business the encyclopedia business in
the days of leather-bound books was
basically a distribution business most
of the cost was the commission to the
salesman the cd-rom and then the
internet came along new technologies
made the distribution of knowledge many
orders of magnitude cheaper and the
encyclopedia industry collapsed it's now
of course a very familiar story
this in fact more generally was the
story of the first generation of the
internet economy it was about falling
transaction cars breaking up value
chains and therefore allowing
disintermediation or what we call
deconstruction
one of the questions i was occasionally
asked was well what's going to replace
the encyclopedia when britannica no
longer has a business model and it was a
while before the answer became manifest
now of course we know what it is it's
the wikipedia
now what's special about the wikipedia
is not its distribution what's special
about the wikipedia is the way it's
produced the wikipedia of course is
encyclopedia created by its users and
this in fact defines what you might call
the second decade of the internet
economy the decade in which the internet
as a noun became the internet as a verb
it became a set of conversations the era
in which user generated content and
social networks became the dominant
phenomenon
now what that really meant in terms of
the porter henderson framework was the
collapse of certain kinds of economies
of scale it turned out that tens of
thousands of autonomous individuals
writing encyclopedia could do just as
good a job and certainly a much cheaper
job than professionals in a hierarchical
organization so basically what was
happening was that one layer of this
value chain was becoming fragmented as
individuals could take over where
organizations were no longer needed
but there's another question that
obviously this graph poses which is okay
we've gone through two decades does
anything distinguish the third
and what i'm going to argue is that
indeed something does distinguish the
third and it maps exactly onto the kind
of porter henderson logic that we've
been talking about and that is about
data
if we go back to around 2000 a lot of
people were talking about the
information revolution and it was indeed
true that the world's stock of data was
growing indeed growing quite fast but it
was still at that point overwhelmingly
analog
we go forward 2007 not only had the
world's stock of data exploded
but there'd been this massive
substitution of digital for analog
and more important even than that if you
look more carefully at this graph what
you'll observe is that about a half of
that digital data is information that
has an ip address it's on a server or
it's on a pc
but having an ip address means that it
can be connected to any other data that
has an ip address it means it becomes
possible to put together half of the
world's knowledge in order to see
patterns an entirely new thing
if we run the numbers forward to today
it probably looks something like this
we're not really sure if we run the
numbers forward to 2020 we of course
have an exact number courtesy of idc's
curious the future is so much more
predictable than the present
um
and
what it implies is a hundred fold
multiplication in the stock of
information that is connected via an ip
address
now if the number of connections that we
can make is proportional to the number
of pairs of data points 100 fold
multiplication in the quantity of data
is a 10 000 fold multiplication in the
number of patterns that we can see in
that data this just in the last 10 or 11
years this i would submit is a sea
change a profound change in the
economics of the world that we live in
the first human genome that of james
watson was mapped as the culmination of
the human genome project in the year
2000 and it took about 200 million
dollars and about 10 years of work to
map just one person's genomic makeup
since then the costs of mapping the
genome have come down in fact they come
down in recent years very dramatically
indeed to the point where the cost is
now below a thousand dollars and it's
confidently predicted that by the year
2015 it will be below a hundred dollars
a five or six order of magnitude drop in
the cost of genomic mapping in just a
15-year period an extraordinary
phenomenon
now
in the days when
mapping a genome cost millions or even
tens of thousands it was basically a
research enterprise scientists would
gather some representative people and
they would see patterns and they try to
make generalizations about human nature
and disease from the abstract patterns
they find from these particular selected
individuals
but when the genome can be mapped for a
hundred bucks ninety nine dollars while
you wait
then what happens is it becomes retail
it becomes above all clinical you go to
the doctor with a cold and if he or she
hasn't done it already the first thing
they do is map your genome at which
point what they're now doing is not
starting from some abstract knowledge of
genomic medicine and trying to work out
how it applies to you but they're
starting from your particular genome
now think of the power of that think of
where that takes us when we can combine
genomic data with clinical data with
data about drug interactions with the
kind of ambient data that devices like
our phone and medical sensors will
increasingly be collected think what
happens when we collect all of that data
and we can put it together in order to
find patterns we wouldn't see before
this i would suggest perhaps it will
take a while but this will drive a
revolution in medicine fabulous lots of
people talk about this but there's one
thing that doesn't get much attention
how is that model of colossal sharing
across all of those kinds of databases
compatible with the business models of
institutions and organizations and
corporations that are involved in this
business today
if your business is based on proprietary
data if your competitive advantage is
defined by your data how on earth is
that company or is that society in fact
going to achieve the value that's
implicit in the technology they can't
so essentially what's happening here and
genomics is merely one example of this
is that technology is driving the
natural scaling of the activity
beyond the institutional boundaries
within which we have been used to
thinking about it and in particular
beyond the institutional boundaries in
terms of which business strategy as a
discipline is formulated
the basic story here is that what used
to be
vertically integrated oligopolistic
competition among essentially similar
kinds of competitors
is evolving by one means or another from
a vertical structure to a horizontal one
why is that happening it's happening
because transaction costs are plummeting
and because scale is polarizing the
plummeting of transaction costs weakens
the glue that holds value chains
together and allows them to separate the
polarization of scale economies towards
the very small small is beautiful
allows for
scalable communities to substitute for
conventional corporate production
the scaling in the opposite direction
towards things like big data drive the
structure of business towards the
creation of new kinds of institution
that can achieve that scale
but either way a typically vertical
structure gets driven to becoming more
horizontal
the logic isn't just about big data if
we were to look for example at the
telecommunications industry you can tell
the same story about fiber optics if we
look at the pharmaceutical industry or
for that matter university research you
can say exactly the same story about
so-called big science and in the
opposite direction if we look say at the
energy sector where all the talk is
about how households will be efficient
producers of green energy and
efficient conservers of energy that is
in fact the reverse phenomenon that is
the fragmentation of scale because the
very small can substitute for the
traditional corporate scale
either way what we are driven to is this
horizontalization of the structure of
industries
and that implies fundamental changes in
how we think about strategy it means for
example that we need to think about
strategy as a curation of these kinds of
horizontal structure where things like
business definition and even industry
definition are actually the outcomes of
strategy not something that the strategy
presupposes
it means for example we need to work out
how to accommodate collaboration and
competition simultaneously think about
the genome we need to accommodate the
very large and the very small
simultaneously and we need industry
structures that will accommodate very
very different motivations from the
amateur motivations of people in
communities to maybe the social
motivations of infrastructure built by
governments or for that matter
cooperative institutions built by
companies that are otherwise competing
because that is the only way that they
can get to scale
these kinds of transformation render the
traditional premises of business
strategy obsolete they drive us into a
completely new world they require us
whether we are in the public sector or
the private sector to think very
fundamentally differently about the
structure of business and at last it
makes strategy interesting again
thank you